[Music]
the moment a gas tanker stuck under a
bridge exploded into flames
it was outside the Tambo Memorial
Hospital inside the impact collapsed the
roof and left debris strewn around the
emergency room
nearby homes were also damaged as flames
spread from the sight of the explosion
residents from a nearby Elderly Care
home were evacuated it was more like a
bomb we inside the house then it
happened again
dead bump then we went out to like
what's going on there then we saw there
was Flames we saw fire under the bridge
like what was going on what's going on
then we saw a tanker which was painting
had been reportedly delivering gas to
the hospital when it got stuck under a
low bridge
the Volkswagen fire crew responded
speedily
and on arrival they found the clock
that was well alight
they tried to extinguish
the fire but unfortunately
the tanker exploded
and six of the firefighters were injured
in an unknown number of bystanders were
also injured
the Flames continued to burn for hours
railway lines have also been damaged and
investigators are examining exactly how
and why a routine delivery could have
ended so tragically Sonic Gallego Al
Jazeera